hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve redundant connections but
before i do i just want to mention if
you have any problem suggestions you can
feel free to leave those in the comments
i do have a
pretty large backlog that i'm working
through right now so it might take me a
couple weeks to get to your suggested
problem so this is a pretty good problem
to solve
this can actually be solved in a naive
way which is going to be o of n squared
and that's just a basic like depth first
search solution for it for this graph
similar to many other graph problems but
you can actually reduce this
to a regular o of n a more optimized
solution and that actually requires a
algorithm that you might not have seen
before
union find it's a rare algorithm to need
on leak code so most people don't use it
but this problem can use union find to
get a much better solution
i'm also going to explain why we're
allowed to use the union find algorithm
in this problem because it's not super
clear
so we're given a definition a tree is an
undirected graph
that contains no cycles so basically
this is the key an undirected graph that
contains no cycles
we're given a graph that started as a
tree started as a graph that was
undirected
and had no cycles we had n nodes these
nodes are labeled from
one all the way to n but we ended up
adding
one additional edge and we know every
edge basically just connects
two vertices and this edge is undirected
so so this
edge ended up connecting two two
vertices and this edge
did not already exist in the graph in
this case the graph
is represented as an array of edges and
the number of edges is basically
n basically the number of edges is equal
to the number of nodes that we have
as i mentioned every edge is going to be
connecting two nodes together
so we want to return an edge that can be
removed from the graph
that will turn the graph back into a
tree
if there are multiple edges that we can
remove that will turn the graph back
into a tree
then we will return the last edge in the
input that that basically satisfies that
condition
and they guarantee us that in the input
list of edges that were given
every single edge is going to be unique
so let's take a look at this
example notice how if we remove any of
the edges if i remove this
now this graph no longer has a cycle
right because
initially it had this cycle right so if
i remove this
edge it doesn't have a cycle so that
satisfies the condition so does that
mean
one two is the result one two is the
edge that we can return
no because it turns out if i remove this
edge
it also satisfies the condition it
breaks the cycle that we initially had
the same is true for the third edge so
in this case
which of the so which of these three
edges are we going to return basically
the one that occurs
last in the input which is going to be 2
3.
so i guess the next question you might
have is is that always going to be the
case is it if we remove
any of the edges it breaks the cycle so
that are we always going to be returning
whatever the last edge is given to us
not necessarily let's take a look at
another edge if we added let's say two
four basically if i increased the number
of nodes to
from three to four so i added an edge
over here
that connects these two nodes now
if i break and this is the last edge
occurs in our input if i break
this edge does that get rid of the loop
that we have no we still have a loop
over here right so
this breaking this edge does not turn us
into a tree that's what we were looking
for
so we're not always going to be
returning the last edge my next question
to you is
if we have n nodes and we have n edges
right that's what we're given always
we're always given the same number of
nodes same number of edges
is it guaranteed that we're always going
to start out with a loop and the answer
is
yes let me show you the intuition of why
that's true
let's say we start out with two nodes if
i add a
single edge to this notice how we were
able to take
the total number of disjoint graphs we
had two graphs that were not connected
right
once we added an edge we were able to
reduce that number
to one graph right now we have one
connected graph
and you want to know something about a
if you add a new edge to this connected
graph
you are going to create a cycle so for
example in this case
we don't even have any more unique
possible edges we could add other than
for example a
self loop on two or a self loop on one
or just adding
another edge right but we know that the
edges are undirected basically what i'm
saying is
if we keep adding edges to a graph that
is already a connected graph
then we're creating a cycle let's look
at a couple more examples
so now we have four nodes if i add four
edges to this graph that are all unique
edges we are gonna end up with a cycle
it's impossible to
not end up with a cycle if we add four
unique edges to this graph let me show
you why
let's say we added one edge here then we
could add
another edge here right and then we
could add another edge
here and then the fourth edge we could
add would be here
this way we end up with a cycle but hold
on maybe there are other possibilities
right
well maybe instead of connecting these i
can also connect
these oh that ends up with the cycle too
right notice that
maybe we just don't connect this with
anything else maybe we add an edge here
that ends up with a cycle
if i add an edge over here that ends up
with a cycle no matter how we do it we
end up with a cycle
right maybe i start out like this i try
to be clever now what we
still will end up with a cycle and
that's going to be true no matter what
if we have
n nodes and n unique edges we're going
to end up with a cycle
no matter what but my question to you is
how do you
know that adding this edge right let's
say we already have these three edges
how do you know that
adding this edge is creating a cycle for
us it's because
one is already connected with three
three and one are already connected see
how
all four of these nodes are already
connected
so when i add this edge i already knew
there was a path from
three to get to one now i'm creating a
second path
from three to get to one notice how
that's what's creating the cycle
this is the reason why we're allowed to
use the union find algorithm
because we're looking at the connected
graphs and once we add
the once we notice we found an edge in
our input array
that caused us to take a connected graph
and add
another redundant connection that's why
this is called redundant connections we
added another connection that was not
needed
three could already get to one why
bother adding this edge
that created a loop so the last edge
so the first edge in our input array
edges
that causes a redundant connection is
going to be the edge that we return
so the solution we're going to be doing
is union find and we are going to be
doing union find by
rank which is the most efficient way to
do it so what we're going to be doing
is iterating through every single edge
for example
this one one two we know that we start
out with three nodes right because we're
given three edges therefore n equals
three we have three nodes each node is
numbered from one
two to three right so we start out with
three nodes that are not connected with
each other right
and the rank of each of those separate
graphs is one basically the size of the
graph right
what we're gonna be doing is going
through each edge so for example one
two that means we're going to be
connecting one and two
together we're connecting them in the
shape of a tree so one of them is going
to be the parent node of the
other and we're going to be doing that
based on rank so for example
if the size of this graph was
or maybe we had something separate right
maybe we had something like this
if we had one graph of size 2 and
another graph
of size 1 then we would want to add the
smaller graph
as a child of the larger graph
but in this case we know that both of
the ranks or in other words
size is the same of both of these
they're both one so it doesn't really
matter what we do
let's add two as the child of one so
since i added so since now one has
another child the size of this is
actually gonna be two now so let's
update the rank of it
to two but we also have to update the
parent so
initially notice how the parents are all
one two and three what that means is one
is a parent of one right that's
that just basically means it has no
parent and two
is initially a parent of two but notice
now two is not two actually has a real
parent now two has a parent
of one so what we're gonna do is erase
this two
and instead set it to one because now if
we ever
get to two and we wanna know who's the
parent of two we can go
up this link all the way to one and see
that one is a parent of two
next we're going to go to the next edge
one and three this means we're going to
be connecting
one and three together so since one is
the parent of one and three is the
parent of three let's get the ranks of
both of these
the rank of one is going to be two the
rank of three
is going to be one since one has a
larger rank
than three that means three is going to
be the child
of one so let's add three as a child of
one
and by doing that we can also update the
new rank
of one because now the size of this has
actually increased
to three so let's change this to
three and let's update the parent of
three initially three was just the
parent of itself
now we're going to change that to also
being one
because the parent of three is clearly
one now
so now let's go to the last edge in our
input array two
three so what this is telling us is we
want to merge
two and three together basically we want
to connect them together
we're always gonna be connecting by the
parent so what we're gonna do when we
when we have two so far we've done our
union algorithm now we're gonna do the
find
portion of union find every time we're
given two nodes to merge together we
need to
find what their parents are so for to
get two's parent we're gonna go
up the link see that the parent is one
for three
we're going to go up the link see that
its parent is also one
what does that tell us if we're trying
to merge two and three together into the
same graph
if they have the exact same parent which
can be
you know found from the parent array
that means they're
already connected that means if we added
this
new edge to our graph we're adding a
redundant connection
that means that this edge is the edge
that we're going to return
as our result it's the one that we
identified first so with that being said
now let's jump into the code so as
mentioned we are going to have a parent
array so initially we can just
initialize that for every single node
itself is going to be the parent so for
i in
range of the length of edges
plus one because we are starting with
zero even though our nodes are going
from one to n
we are going to have a zero in this
input array just because it makes the
math work out easier we're not actually
going to be using that zero node
and we're also going to have a list of
ranks which initially is just going to
be set to one
so and it's going to be the size of
length of edges
plus one and then we can basically just
define our standard algorithms for
uh union and find so let's start out
with find because it's easier so for
if we were given a node n then we want
to find what its parent is
so we're going to go to its first parent
and when we say parent we want to find
the root parent it's possible
that a parent could go multiple it could
take multiple links to get to the parent
so
we're going to get the first parent of
this parent
of n and it's also possible that n could
basically be the parent of
itself so we're going to basically keep
going until we find
the last root parent so while is
not equal to parent of n
then we're going to basically keep going
up the length so we're going to set p
equal to parent of itself
so while p is not equal to its own
parent we're going to basically keep
going up the link so then we're going to
update p
to the parent of itself but we are going
to add one thing to this algorithm it's
called path compression basically
before we get to this portion what we're
gonna say is for
p we're gonna set its parent actually to
the parent of its parent basically
it's grandparent so we're gonna say its
new parent
parent of p is going to be parent of
its parent and so this part is a little
bit complicated but basically it's
making sure that we
shorten the links as we go up the chain
of parents
so if we had to go up the link one more
time if we had to repeat this
find operation it would be a little bit
faster the next time that we did it
and at the end when this is no longer
the case basically
once we've gotten to the root parent is
when we're going to be returning p
so this function is pretty short the
next one that we're going to be
implementing
is the union function so if we were
given two nodes n1 and n2 and we had to
union them together that's what we're
going to be doing so
to union them we would have to find both
of their root parents first right so
that's why we implemented the find
function first so we're going to want to
get p1 and p2 the parents of n1 and n2
we can do that with our find function
find n1
and find n2 one case is that
both of the parents are equals for
example p1 is equal to p2
in that case we're going to return false
because we cannot complete this
operation so we're going to say
return false if can't complete meaning
they're already merged
that's how we're gonna know that we
found a redundant connection so we'll
return false if they have the same
parent if they don't have the same
parent then we're gonna union them we're
gonna be unioning them by rank so if
the rank of p1 is greater than the rank
of p2 that means that rank that means p1
is going to be the parent of p2
if the opposite is true then that means
p2 is going to be the parent of p1 in
the else condition but let's do the if
condition first
so p1 is going to be the parent so what
we're going to do is for p2 we're going
to set its parent
equal to p1 we also then have to update
the rank
of p1 because it's now has more children
than it had before
so we're going to add to the rank of p1
basically whatever the rank of p2 was
prior to union unioning them together
in the else condition we're basically
going to be do the doing the opposite so
for p1 we're going to set its parent
equal to p2
and we're going to add to the rank of p2
i just noticed that i called my uh
parent
array parent but i've been referencing
it as pair
so let's just shorten this to par and
the last thing we're gonna do in this is
return true if we were able to
successfully union them together so
let's return true
and that's basically the entire code now
we get to the easy part where we're
actually going to be calling these union
find functions
so let's go through every single edge so
for n1n2 this pair of edges
this pair of nodes in our edges input
array we're gonna be calling
union on these two n1 and two and
if it returns false so if not the result
of this function
then we have to return this edge n1
and 2 as the resulting edge that they're
looking for and we know for sure
it's guaranteed that at least one edge
is going to lead to a redundant
connection in this problem so this is
definitely going to execute we don't
have to put a return statement out here
so this
is the entire code so i hope that you
learned something today i hope this
video was helpful maybe you learned
union finding it today
and it's usually something that you can
just memorize that if you need to
so i hope this was helpful if it was
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching